una domanda ma secondo voi se colpiscono
azione che ha attraversato il numero mi
uccide
lì uccisa o scherzando ragazzi perfetto
insegna zio fabi a guidare prima cosa si
tiene la testa fuori dal parabrezza e
poi tutto il culo fuori da parabrezza è
questo il modo più sicuro per guidare i
ragazzi poi e poi si esplode la mia
testa è libera
[Musica]
io non saprò mai cosa mi ha spinto a
fare questo video signori molti di voi
mi conoscono perché molto tempo fa circa
sei anni fa ho portato sul mio canale un
gioco che ho maledetto per tutta la mia
vita per quanto mi abbia fatto fare
anche un po successo tutto il resto per
carità di dio
però ho dovuto interromperlo perché era
diventato molto molto simile alla fine
non c'era quasi mai della novità vera è
quindi ho smesso di farlo non ho
intenzione di riportarlo sul canale mai
più lo farci questo unico episodio dopo
un sacco di tempo che cosa hai fatto è
più visi mentre non c'ero che è successo
volevo vedere questa cosa qua non lo
riporterò sul canale quindi non mi
ammazzate addio buono benedetto mi
mancava st musichetta che bello è un po
come quando ti metti le supposte nel
deretano sentire la sua canzone per la
milionesima volta va le ragazze di un
sub rasul levels andiamo su sort by
rating e vediamo se c'è ancora qualcuno
che gioca ad epic games si c'è ancora
gente che ci faccia bene per il scopo è
possibile va bene allora venirsi in un
anno e mezzo è cambiato qualcosa anche
se non penso su perciò yourself promette
bene
c'è un motivo se ho mollato nel tempo è
più vista è morto nel mentre sorry there
was a provare un gioco con delle qualità
solo che sono qualità incomprese niente
non facciamo questo la ciambotto
slipstream playnow allora questo livello
che facevo di continuo visto che non c'è
niente altro cabaret dove lanciare le
bottiglie e farle cadere e farle cadere
[Musica]
ragazzi spero che video vi sia piaciuto
ovviamente non ho perso il mio tocco
perché ci ho fatto i milioni così da
dare una battuta e non è vero perché
questo gioco ed è monetizzato anche dal
demonio
nel secondo video di happy questi
guadagno è zero devi pagare tu e youtube
permettono perché non ti danno niente
col cydia monetizzano tutto il video
quindi non serve a niente farebbe se lo
fai perché ti diverti lo faccio per voi
è più il gente che si spalma il canale
youtube e questo è un album imposti col
team devi solo arrivare alla fine ma io
con un solo tentativo per ora non ho
perso il tocco dei tasti e me li ricordo
a memoria almeno quello
prendi la boxe è difficilissimo come si
potrebbe mai fare una roba del genere ma
scusami dai e niente secoli di youtube
non mi hanno insegnato nulla però ho
vinto con la gamba con un pezzo di corpo
molto bene se questa è buona
questa è buona sono morto in realtà
quindi non ho vinto però
ecco come un fatto non lo so neanche io
però va bene il prossimo 99 per cento
sky si chiamava ecco questi sono
giochini che puoi fare
nel senso che che si possono creare ma
mai capito come fanno sono scarso liutai
e li proviamo
questo non era un gioco possono marzo
non mi pare non ci arrivo sono scarso
dai dai dai dai
salta all'ultimo molto bene molto bene
shift lo slide ti pare che hanno fatto
una roba così [ __ ] e i livelli più
votati sono ancora quelli che non
funzionano sono ancori impossible quando
fanno roba così [ __ ] dopo sarà sotto poi
c'è una fisica in attimino un post
minchia però dettagli le docce che sta
arrivando e cosa veloce veloce cos'è sta
roba rega sono misteri dolce o mister
rido spiegami il tuo problema di vita ci
costa caricando cosa stai caricandomi
stai riavviando il computer mi stai
hackerando il canale cos'è un altro
livello space jam militari be nice ha
fatto un miliardo di livelli ma poca
vita sociale c'hanno i creatori sole
cos'è dove abbassarmi immaginato che è
partito un missile lentissimo l'ho
saltato picchia lo picchiò quanto mamma
mia quanta dinamica in stagione contro
vabbè vabbè questo successo
ok calcolato così succede non ho capito
niente di quello che è successo al
bottone schiacciata schiacciati
schiacciano bravo di end non ho capito
niente però è stato finissimo basic
level 1.0 è perché il resto dei livelli
come basic level niente manco questo
degli scappamenti devo aspettare che
passino i gol si va bene ok fin quanto
red block
a posto a posto kimi se senti un odore
particolari anno che non vogliamo i
coltellacci
ok finché tempi ecco tieni la spada lì
dietro bravissimo piano freddo perfetto
quota player
vabbè continuato dal giro ho finalmente
un livello difficile ne sono certo anche
almeno abbia senso cioè pensate se
questo quel livello che ha senso pensa
come sono fatti gli altri nel mio figlio
via però la bici ha vinto noi bueno
porca vacca sono ancora vivo con mio
figlio vai figlio pedala vai a piedi chi
se ne frega buy back
renditi utile fai qualcosa nella vita uk
schifoso basta parte qui son riuscito a
fare cosa da fare ma che devo fà sono
vivo sono vivo non ho capito cosa
succederebbe cowboy è un livello
difficile però vabbè per me va bene così
tanto non sono capace non solo non sono
più capaci
la storia però non è importante saper
vincere ma l'importante è smettere di
registrare per i jap in the wall lo
saltare nel dentro il muro a devo
toccare il traguardo non è
difficilissimo verso in teoria dovrebbe
essere abbastanza easy fermi ma dai
laghi sfiga possibile
è strano perché si riveli come li facevo
come il nulla tempo fa quando ero
giovane quando non guardavo ancora i
cantieri quel periodo di cigo da adulto
mettere le mani dietro la schiena e
fissero i computer che faranno è più il
3.0 insomma world trovo sapete cosa lo
sport trovo altro trono non lo so
comunque non ho ancora capito come si
dice dopo mille anni di epic tu prendi
la spada e la tiria la gente e la gente
fa quello che dovrebbe fare tutti i
giorni si leva dal capo a molto bene
sono un fenomeno come è possibile però
l'ultimo lo prenderò mai a meno che non
faccio così l'ultimo è difficilissimo ma
dai ma come
qualcuno lo becchi niente non ho beccato
messo a parte che comunque non è
l'ultimo con l'ultima a sinistra e non
ho beccato manco quello da rifacciamo
tesoro non è mai facile ma con un po di
pratica si fa tutto tipo lui molto bene
tipo quello sotto molto bene uno sopra
molto bene 3 spalle per beccare l'ultimo
12 notre a ragazza sciocca gare è
schiatta o perfetto perfetto sono morti
tutti e anche volate una gamba che
volevo prendere problema
dovresti scendere io dovrei scendere per
vincere interessi scendi scendi sono
incastrato non scendo non scende quindi
si stanno lì morale che succede
vabbè basta trash talk libertà per the
sun game questa roba o basan o sun aiuto
becca io devo beccare cos'è sta roba e
nuovo questo non ho mai fatto devo
beccare le cose ragazze difficilissimo
centrale non ci si riesce mai
e veramente difficile hanno aumentato la
difficoltà di questo gioco sono
stupefatto o invece entrata
[Musica]
io mi stupisco sempre di più degli
insulsi ta di questo gioco ma devo
prendere il tizio lo prendo anche io e
mi the hulk hogan
va beh secondo me si è fatto malissimo
però andiamo avanti lo stesso forse
avete capito forse come mai questo gioco
non è family friendly
c'era un motivo non sono scemo o pazzo
per i suoli oggi il poker a un gel fa
che non era finissimo cioccolato di
rientrare nel buco le suole suo my
friends che o mamma mia che schifo e
cipro
cioè sono andato a di oltre alla
vittoria cioè mi son schiantato contro
un muro ho fatto ho distrutto il muro
non ho capito come ragazzi sono accadute
le cuffie venute alla vista di sta roba
spero che il video di sia piaciuta larga
è stato bellissimo provare a fare un
micro tuffo nel passato per vedere un po
come si era ridotto
è questo il nostro caro è più diciamo
che erano una vita che non lo facevo
perché ormai come vedete tutto uguale
cioè non è cambiato in un anno e mezzo
che non lo faccio è rimasto identico non
è cambiato niente
ora vi sia piaciuto ragazzi consenso
video piaciuto quel momento mi piace
anche a vari social che come noto nella
descrizione sera sera prestiti
iscrivetevi e non ci dividiamo ad un
prossimo video da ragazzi
[Musica]